garrett called he hasn't pitched in over
two weeks he's been sidelined tested
positive for covet 19. they're not sure
exactly how long he's going to go in
this ball game and we'll see
how he pitches tonight and ohtani
will start it off
you see his numbers 270 won an ops of
1.017 what he's doing this season
is just amazing both pitching
and hitting the 2-2
swinging and a miss got him
ohtani down on strikes well welcome back
coney it's uh right there
looks like he didn't lose his velocity
ball coming right at you at 99. and by
ohtani there's david fletcher he's
hitting 302
two homers and 39 rbis
strike three
fletcher down looking of all the angel
hitters this guy hits him best justin
upton eight for 22 a homer
and four runs driven in in his career
against cole
upton
drives that ball deep to left and gone
and the numbers don't lie
for jay up
that's a little uptown funk in gotham
city
mike trout liking that smiling as he's
going down to greet his good buddy
16th home run continues to swing the bat
well
against garrett cole wow what a shot
that was
that that sounded
like a home run jared walsh is having a
terrific rookie year he grand slammed
against the yankees when the angels made
that improbable comeback he payoff
struck him out swinging change off speed
well cole struck out the side gave up a
home run to update getting ready to work
is angel's lefty jose suarez 23 year old
left-hander five and five record coming
into tonight's action here's joey gallo
the tying run of first base with one out
and the three
swung on line to right it is high that
is far that is gone
it is a two-run blast in the second deck
and right joey jackson
hey it's a two-round blast that ball got
out of here in about a second and a half
well he's pal joey a two-run home run
and the yankees take a 2-1 lead marsh is
at 86 at bats hitting at 209 and two
homers 10 rbs
strike three marsh down looking well
they took to the second inning before
you saw triple digits from garrett cole
that's a good sign
now stassi nicole is set and the pitch
struck him out swinging high fastball
that was 98. still coming in batting
250.
and he goes down looking strikeout
number six for cole moneyball right
there if you're a pitcher well
you can make a lot of money throwing
that eric cole in his fourth inning of
work they'll deal with justin upton
swing and a miss strikeout number seven
for cole
upton caught up to one this first time
up but not this late movement up in the
strike zone completely fine walsh went
down swinging back in the angels first
inning
swing and a miss
cole's just mowing them down there's the
catcher max stassi he's a right-handed
who struck out his first time swing and
a miss
strikeout number nine well it's the 15th
time an angels hitter has swung at one
of garrett cole's pitches and missed
tonight
is dassey not happy
there's joe adele be a 1-0 to the tall
right-hand hitter
and the pitch is swung on and driven to
deep right center gardner davis going
back makes a one-handed catch
jonathan davis saved a double and a run
he raced from center toward right center
and at the yankee bullpen wall
made a terrific catch
call nine strikeouts one walk through
five innings top of the order starting
with ohtani here in the sixth high fly
ball
deep right center going back as judge
on the track or stanton excuse me and he
makes the play
for the first out
so ohtani gave it a ride but
stan makes the play on the warning track
and that'll bring up justin upton
grounded to third charging odor bobbles
and allowing upton to region
the inning to continue
scored an e5 and that's also the end of
the evening for garrett cole
with walsh coming up paul gets a big
hand as he pitched a very good game
he leaves with a 2-1 lead
this is stanton with the bags loaded
and nobody out
yankee stadium
down a run c check one two
got him slider
now luke voight
fastball ground ball slowly hit
one there fletcher's turn got him there
a double play thought they had no chance
richard turning a double play on that
one fletch what a catch and throw
and then the stretch the yoga man at
first the yankees go to joelli rodriguez
the lefty
to deal with shohei ohtani
strike three ohtani down looking
a 94 mile an hour sinker on the outside
corner and rodriguez comes in and gets
the major league's home run leader
looking to end the top of the eighth
inning interesting to see how chad green
reacts here and a save opportunity here
in the ninth inning
well three blown saves six point four
three alright four home runs allowed in
his last 12 games and he's eight for 11
in his career closing out games in the
ninth inning or later all three of those
blown saves have been since july 11th
ground ball of first le mayhew is right
there steps on the back one down now to
bring up justin upton responsible for
the angels only run the home run against
cole in the first inning and the 3-2
pitch swing and a miss he got him
with the fastball
two down
so here's walsh
line drive eight base hit down the left
field line it kicks off the sidewall
gardner fields he'll fire to second and
holds walsh
to a single that's a big play
by gardner who just came in for defense
you don't want walsh in scoring position
with the tying run so now here's phil
gosling against green tying runs on
first
base strike three ball game's over in
the yankees win 2-1
chad green nails it down garrett cole
gets the victory a big two-run home run
by joey gallo and the yankees win
another nail biter 2-1 at the stadium